you have to practice
what does that mean sit with your kids
and play freaking Candyland until your
brain spins sideways
yeah take one of your young kids and
just go for a walk and point out every
leaf and every Acorn and if you find a
little
um I don't know a little piece of fruit
on the ground throw it at your kid and
let him throw it back at you
or if y'all go swimming do a giant
Cannonball first
go out on the boat and go really really
really slow or get some kayaks and go
even slower
you just need a couple of years of
teaching your body and I did I am
intentional a couple of years takes a
while
to teach your body
just stop running